talking of working with uh the rock I
mean that was really one of your Heroes
I was obsessed with him but like
it did sound a bit feedback
so you made you made jungle cruise I
really like the Rock
s with him and was it after that you
came home and found your exercise book
yeah I found my Sketchbook from when I
was at school and in it there were some
drawings some sketches that I'd done of
the rock because I was that obsessed
with him now how old how old was it how
old is him naked on the shows
how old are you when you do this I was
like maybe 13 14.
yeah it was my art project at school and
I drew loads of pictures of The Rock and
I sent them to Emily Blunt and said
please don't tell him obviously she
sends them straight to him so now he
thinks I'm even weirder than you already
did
does he know that you did them when you
were like young or does he think you're
doing them now no
no no I've just gone home from the shoot
and I've been here and sending me a day
I really miss you no I did those when I
was a child not as a grown man but now
you found other sketches in your ex
that's really freaked me out now I'm
gonna have to message him and clarify
just to let you know these were from 10
years ago they were the ones I've done
recently
you found other sketches in in the
exercise book it's quite weird it is a
Sketchbook it was from when I was at
boarding school and so the other
sketches in it are I remember quite
vividly when I was at school because we
couldn't you know get access to the
internet so it was quite a lot of sort
of young horny boys away at boarding
school and my friends used to ask me to
draw quite sort of soft core
pornographic material so I used to draw
sort of half-naked ladies for my friends
here's a beautiful picture here's a
beautiful picture of uh the glamor model
Katie Price formerly known as Jordan
yeah it's tasteful that is
who knows that I've just signed him at
the top as well
you have started like that white hole
and a little copyright thing
okay
weird little boy like someone will be
trying to steal this image
patriotic as well no so oh yes very big
water so this is Jordan now this net
this next one's incredible I have no
idea what this next one is okay so we
are showing that I didn't know whether
you wanted to show this or not what is
it is it now it's from the SketchBook
you sent it to us I don't remember it's
the end of the Sketchbook and it's odd
okay
terrified well it's should we see it
yeah this was foreign
[Laughter]
thank you
I wonder what the inspiration was for
this what were you thinking at this
moment in time well Cynthia
I think that's a conversation I should
have with a therapist
[Music]